Welcome to this talks at Google and our Seattle office.
Uh,
today we have Dr Brett Finlay joining us
since about 200 years ago when humanity first discovered microorganisms.
We've pretty much tried our best to get rid of them and while the number of
cholera infested wells has gone down,
the risk for other diseases like asthma has actually gone up.
And recent science has shown us something that we've kind of started feeling in
our guts,
pun intended,
um,
that are over sanitized world.
And our attention to hyper cleanliness is actually affecting our children's
health in a not so good way.
So doctor Brett Findlay is an,
uh,
professor of microbiology and immunology at the University of British Columbia
where he is published just under 500 papers.
Okay.
Um,
I think we're like what,
four short of 500 we talked about.
Yeah.
Um,
and has enjoyed international recognition for his work.
He led the team that sequence the SARS genome and then develop the vaccine for
it.
Okay.
He plays a jazz saxophone.
He's,
he's got more awards than I know how to pronounce,
but he is most notably an officer of the order of Canada,
which is Canada's highest civilian recognition.
It's kind of like being an,
the knighted,
um,
and his,
his book,
let them eat dirt is now being translated into 11 languages.
So let us welcome Dr Brent Finlay.
[inaudible].
Thank you Maria.
Thank you all for coming and giving.
She's already got half the talk done,
so it's perfect.
So yeah,
that's kind of the concept I want to discuss today about,
um,
we will talk about kids,
but I'm also going to talk about microbes affected,
not just kids affecting people of,
of other ages,
including the elderly and other ages.
So my career,
I've worked a lot on diarrhea,
Salmonella,
e coli.
So I warn you,
I have a perverse sense of humor.
That's why we're restricted for fecal content here.
So,
you know,
let,
let's start,
when you think about,
you know,
what's important to this world and you know,
I hope you're all sort of starting to think,
you know,
yacht island place,
diamond ring,
whatever.
But you know,
really when it comes right down to it in terms of society,
the important things our kids,
cause they're really our future.
So picture of Kid,
right?
And um,
nice,
cute baby.
By the time I have this talk,
I want you to think of kids more like this coded in microbes.
So as very sad that um,
we've known there's microbes in and on us for a long,
long time.
So Andy van leaving hook was in the Netherlands and he was,
he made these textiles but he was a passionate lens grinder.
He's like making magnifying glasses and we could look at his fabrics and dies.
And he got so good at polishing these lenses.
He basically built microscopes and like any good scientist,
you know,
what do you do when you build the mic?
So you'll be looking at things,
right?
So we started looking in rainwater and they did a fascinating experiment where
we actually swapped out his mouth in his teeth and that held up the microscope.
And you saw all these animalcules,
all these little Wrigley things in there.
And basically he made the stunning observation that there's more microbes than
he could see in his mouth.
Then all the people living in Holland,
which is where he lived and this is 330 odd years ago and don't believe them,
all the crazy Dutchman.
But over time they've,
you know,
they kept writing all these letters to the British academy and they just throw
them out.
And finally they sent someone to actually look and holy smokes,
he was right.
And that's when microbiology was discovered.
So in order for a long,
long time,
that microbes play a big part in this world and we just go,
you can't see him.
Doesn't mean they're important.
I mean,
they basically were here long before us.
They built the oxygen that we breathe.
It's worth,
didn't have any optional that came online.
And we only think about the big ones,
the plants and animals,
which are actually just a tiny portion of,
of the tree of life that we see here.
And they were here long before us.
They're gonna be here long after us.
There's a lot of microbes,
have a lot of different kinds in this world.
Okay.
They discover these things straight a 30 years ago they had no idea what these
microbes do.
It was a neat novelty.
You can find these Wrigley things all over our bodies and things.
Then these two guys came along,
Louis pasture and Robert Coq,
one German run freshmen.
So they hate each other,
right?
They're competitors and but what these two guys did and their teams and other
people in the world is,
they basically showed that microbes actually cause infectious diseases and that
was a big finding because up until then they had no idea what caused.
There was all these,
you know,
thoughts of maybe it's bad air,
swamp gas.
No one knew how infections work.
So these guys showed that things like Yo call Rick cause disease and anthrax and
tuberculosis.
Then Louis Pasture also showed if he cook these things,
you killed them.
Pasteurization.
That's where it comes from.
You couldn't transmit the disease anymore.
So this is 125 years ago and this was cool.
This beads that if we kill these microbes,
we wouldn't have disease,
right?
So society went on this huge kick to basically get rid of microbes and um,
you know,
this is World War II.
The antibiotics were invented.
These things were amazing.
You could actually save lives by these antibiotics,
Adam,
to bacteria,
and they would actually then start to lyse bacteria and actually kill these
things.
We brought in sanitation,
we started getting rid of the rats,
we had garbage collection and you know,
we went on this bandwagon that let's get rid of these microbes because they're
causing these diseases.
And you know,
we've got to this extent now that you know,
this kills 99.9% of bacteria.
Yay,
right?
We can get rid of these things with these antibacterial things.
And it worked beautifully in the 1914 to 20 era.
30% of kids less than one year of age died of infections.
Now less than 0.1% do.
So it worked cleanest.
Great.
And um,
you can look at it pretty much any infectious diseases you want.
There's a bunch of listed here.
This is 50 years of of humanity and these infections,
these goes down.
We have vaccines,
we have antibiotics,
we've cleaned up our world.
And so as I told you,
I worked on infectious diseases,
right?
I look at this one curve.
This is not a growth industry,
right?
I'm in trouble here.
Got to find something to help us to do.
So this is actually only the first half of the curve.
It's the second half that I think is so telling about society.
So again,
the same 50 years,
look around the world.
What do people have now?
They've got asthma,
they've got diabetes,
they've got obesity,
they've got inflammatory bowel disease,
the western society kind of diseases.
What has happened at 50 years,
because that's what two genetic generations are humans.
It takes a hundred generations to really get genetic changes in the population.
So we've evolved in 50 years,
we've done something to our world.
And so the concept I'm going to try and get across is we've actually gotten to
clean.
And actually you will start to see these microbes are actually influencing the
diseases that affect us on a daily basis.
So back to microbes,
you're more microbes than you are.
Human students are pissed off when I tell them that.
But the number of microbes in and on you outnumbers the number of human cells,
there's more microbes on,
they contain 15 times more DNA then homo sapiens in you.
So these microbes have a big influence on us.
And the reason we start to know this and start to understand this is new
sequencing technologies of loudest to characterize these microbes without having
district them on a plate and then grow.
So you know,
the mid two thousands the human genome project came online and that was a
massive sequencing project to sequence the human genome and they daisy chained
all these sequencers together and the world got together,
we actually sequenced the human genome.
That was a huge milestone.
It's science.
We can now know what the genetic coding of humans are.
But the problem is they spent all this money sending up all these sequencers and
training all these people.
And once his guys finished the human genome,
they sort of looked at each other.
What are we going to do now guys?
You know,
we've got to find something and someone said,
let's sequence microbes.
There's lots of,
it will be six think forever and we'll keep our jobs.
So that turned into what's now known as the human microbiome project,
which is to sequence basically all the microbes in an honest,
and it's been a stunning generation of data.
It was just generates phenomenal amounts of data,
of sequencing,
all these different microbes
and we're learning all sorts of things about them.
There's a heck of a lot in them.
There's a hundred trillion microbes in your body on your body,
10 trillion in the gut.
To put that in perspective,
tip your little finger,
cut that off.
That's about one gram.
Let's pretend it's feces.
I told you I'm going to be gross here.
One gram of feces contains more microbes that all the people in the world,
so you can marvel at that tomorrow morning and go to the camp.
Um,
there's a lot of microbes there.
And W you know,
we,
we really started to realize this.
I was bored one night and so I basically say,
no,
I went,
I brushed my teeth really well.
Then they swab the cheek cell.
It's like leaving hooked in,
and then I put on a microscope and they stained it.
And what do you see?
See this gorgeous,
beautiful cell.
That's me,
right?
Nice nucleus and selling everything,
but look at all the microbes stuck to it.
That's just normal mouth.
And any of you can do this experiment.
You're,
your mouths are full.
These microbes,
they're sort of all different sizes and shapes.
So we're all these critters.
They're basically wherever your body is exposed to the environment,
so they're on your skin,
you know they're in the oral cavity.
For example,
the gastrointestinal track,
they basically increase the numbers as you go down.
And by far the highest numbers of microbes is in the lower bowel and lower
intestine,
and there's no air there.
It's Anaerobic,
and that's where they live.
Urogenital tract,
there's microbes there.
And each of these places is a different environment.
So each of these places have different microbes.
The microbes on your arm pit,
or even a very different,
which is wet than than your scalp,
which is dry.
So each of these places in the body has these different microbes.
But what we're learning is that actually everyone has a unique composition of
microbes.
Genetically,
we're 99.9% the same.
We're very well in the chromosome for male and females were very,
very similar,
but we're not at,
there is no single microbe is found in all people around the world and each
person is at best,
50% of the same as someone else.
So each of you has your own unique microbes.
And so when we talk about things like personalized medicine,
I argued we should talking about the micros because that's what's really
different between people.
So one of these things do over life while at that first magnificent moment when
you're born,
your mother gives you your very first birthday present,
which is a big bolus of fecal vaginal microbes.
Gross.
But it's actually really important.
That's when you kickstart your body for these microbes.
Then as a kid and hills and eats these things,
you increase the number of microbes in there and then it sort of bounces around
in early life and then it sort of hits a kid microbiome and that stays pretty
constant until you go through puberty.
And the hormonal changes give you an adult microbiome,
your microbiome from pretty much from since you hit finished puberty till really
65 or so,
it was pretty constant.
Unless you do something like move to another country,
become a vegetarian,
I don't know,
swear off alcohol.
Um,
it,
it changes if you change your environment.
But if you live the same,
your microbes stay the same.
And at the other end of the book,
end of life,
post 65,
your microbes fall off a cliff.
And we're just starting to realize that actually there's a lot of interference,
these microbes in terms of aging and there's some hope that we can actually
influence aging because if we can improve the microbes as you age,
maybe we'll do,
okay.
So we're full of micros.
Big Deal.
Do we need this to live?
Yes you do.
Microbes are essential for life.
So the experiment's been done in both people and animals that let's start with
um,
this guy named David veteran.
He was a kid many years ago in California before he was born.
They knew he would not have an immune system,
he didn't have it,
and we're not immune system.
You Die.
Pretty simple.
So what they did is it birth devices,
Arion section.
So you can actually sterly take the kid out and then put it in a sterile
container.
You only feed them sterile food and water.
Now he would die except that they then fed them essential vitamins,
cause that's microbes make these things and he can sort of live.
And he basically spent 12 years of his life inside this bubble became known as
the bubble boy.
He then died at 12 and infection.
But so they're able to keep them alive by giving these key things.
But the experiments we do in animals who are very similar,
we do the same things.
We call these things germ free animals.
That's just code for microbe free.
And studying these things.
We're learning that these microbes affect how the brain develops,
how the gut develops,
how the immune system develops.
These are normal pieces of us that we need to develop normally and these germ
free animals,
they're really strange in terms of,
you know,
how they actually develop,
okay,
we need him to live.
Do they have any effect on disease?
This is where it gets really interesting that take a look at this list of
diseases here,
you know all that sort of some of the western society diseases,
all those diseases lifted there,
the microbes in the disease patients are different than the healthy ones.
That doesn't prove it's causing the disease.
But there's this association and in some cases I'll tell you about,
there actually are seem to be contributing significant to the CS.
Okay?
They're somehow involved in these diseases.
Can we use that therapeutically?
The answer is actually yes,
you can do a fecal transfer.
I tried calling the number but it didn't answer.
Excuse me.
So there's this infection called clustered,
I mean difficile,
you cared called C diff.
So let's pretend you're old.
You're going to the hospital and you're going to have,
say a hip transplant.
The surgeon's fill you up with antibiotics.
What do antibiotics do?
They carpet bomb the microbes.
The idea is to get rid of the microbes.
So if the surgeon actually slips with a knife or whatever,
you don't get infections.
So it's to block the infections.
The problem is you're killing the good ones with the bat.
And what that does is it creates a niche for this c difficile to crawl in.
So if it's competitive in the gut,
which it is,
it's very competitive.
It's hard for microbes to come in.
But if you get rid of all these cause any bugs,
it crawls in,
and this has been a big cause of death.
Many,
many people,
they go to the hospital for an operation,
they died due to this.
So this is a disease caused by antibiotics.
So how do you treat it?
The give antibiotics,
while that treats maybe 20% of this,
basically what can be a fatal disease.
So then someone reason,
well if we could somehow replenish the feces in the gut where these microbes
live,
we might be able to boot it out and it couldn't then cause disease.
So they actually did fecal transfers.
You can do this two ways.
You can nasal gastric tube down here or anima from the other end.
There's even youtube out there.
How to DIY.
Do not do this yourself because you perforate your bowel,
you will die.
But all it takes is a blender according to these videos.
Uh,
so but the neat thing is at least with this disease,
it cured 94% of these people by simply putting healthy feces from a different
person.
It was these Persian.
That's fantastic.
That means we can actually start to think about treating diseases by changing
the microbes.
So let's spend a little bit of time more time talking about kids because this is
where the microbes seem to have a major influence.
And I've already said as a kid is born,
they bounced.
The microbes kind of bounce around the first two,
three years of life.
Then what,
about three years or so?
The micro is a pretty stable for,
for their childhood.
Well I've already alluded to this that one of the key roles of these microbes
early in life is to help our immune systems developed.
Normally germ free animals,
their immune systems are really whacked.
And what we realize there's several studies now coming out.
They really help the immune system develop a balance so it knows which way to go
cause it goes too far go allergic for example or autoimmune disease type things.
And so they're really key for how this develops.
So I'll tell you a story that that came out of our lab and that's dealing with
asthma.
When I was a kid,
nobody had asthma.
We had one kid in the school that had asthma.
So they must've immune,
right?
Cause they had a puffer and you know when kids are weird they got to hit
Newton's kind of thing.
And yet now you know you go to the playground,
kids take a puff out of the puffer and passes to a friend and then path classes
down the line of slide,
right?
Yeah.
20% of kids have asthma.
And that's just a short two generation time period.
So when you look at as a worldwide,
what you see is it's what we call a developing country disease.
We see it in Canada,
in the US,
we see it in the UK,
we see it in Australia.
These are the,
you know,
the,
the hyper developed countries.
Um,
so it's,
it's associated with something changes in the world.
So there's all sorts of hypothesis.
What is triggering as well,
what's this doing?
This is a due to air pollution,
exposure to certain things.
And there's obviously a lot of work and interest in this area,
but we certainly know it's gone way up in a few years.
So here's a few things that basically will affect your outcome of asthma.
If you live on a farm,
you have a 20% less chance of getting asthma.
And I love this picture.
Can you imagine writing a chicken?
I mean,
this kid's got to have a Greek grin on their face.
Okay,
so living on a form decreases asthma if you born by [inaudible] section.
The simple fact of how you come into this world gives you a 20% difference.
You 20% more risk than if you're born vaginally.
Asthma doesn't kick in until five years later.
How on earth does,
how you come into this world affect how you actually are going to come out.
But we know the microbes in csection kids are different than the microbes
vaginally.
The ones that vaginally,
they have the mother's vaginal microbiome,
which is important for breaking down breast milk.
The csection kids or kid the microbes as much like the mother's skin cause
that's what the kid is exposed to breastfeeding and other skin contact there.
Okay.
There's the APP.
If you have antibiotics in the first year of life,
you again have a much higher rate of asthma and this would be not really well
documented.
What do antibiotics do?
Affect microbes.
And finally,
if you're breastfeeding a child,
you again have a reduced rate of asthma.
So what all of these have in common?
Obviously my hypothesis is microbes,
right?
So the way I got into this is,
um,
we had been using antibiotics to affect diarrheal outcomes in our most models of
diarrhea.
And I came home one night,
I was talking to my wife Jane,
she's a pediatrician.
Infectious Diseases doc cause it,
Hey Jane,
you know,
if we treat these mice with antibiotics,
swing,
shift the microbes and affect their diarrhea.
And she sort of looked at me.
So you know,
Brett,
that's interesting that because there's these neat studies coming out on the use
of antibiotics or any life effecting asthma,
and for whatever reason that comment stuck with me and you know,
being the good husband,
you know,
you don't believe the wife,
right?
So you're going to look it up.
And guys,
we all know wives are right?
Of course she was right.
But I could find the experiment that basically proved that microbes were causing
this album.
There's all these correlations,
but are they proving or not?
So I'll being a scientist,
what do you do?
We do the experiment,
right?
So I had this bright young Grad student,
Shannon Russell was her name,
and she comes bounding into my office and we're going to start of plan a
project.
I'm sure Shannon is thinking,
yeah,
we're going to work in e coli or Salmonella and diarrhea.
I said,
Hey Shannon,
let's work on asthma.
You know,
it was a new graduate.
Students say,
okay,
sure.
And um,
so bless her heart,
she bit the bit the dare.
And away we went.
So we started off with just doing some very simple experiments were in treating
mice with antibiotics.
There's a most asthma model they all use and we're going to see can we affect
the outcome of asthma in an experimental model.
What we did is we took my very early in life or adult mice and just treat with
antibiotics and then induce asthma.
And what we found is that in the early ones,
and these are mice are really young,
they're still,
I'm breastfeeding.
If you shift their microbes with antibodies,
they had profound rates of asthma.
The Guy I worked with,
the asthma,
he'd never seen rates like this yet.
If we did it to adult most,
we didn't see any effect.
So you know,
okay what p we cured most asthma,
this is a,
you know,
a major worldwide problem,
blah blah blah.
So we said,
well let's do it in kids.
So what we did is he grabbed a cohort of kids and we did some experiments in
these kids and so there was this cohort of 2,500 Canadian cans and they'd been
looking at roles of asthma and say if there's a smoker in the house or a dog in
the house kind of thing,
look these risk factors.
And I called these guys up and say,
hey guys,
collect the feces.
And they say,
Oh God,
there's Finley fancies again kind of thing.
You know how really really collect the feces.
So for whatever reason,
I don't know why they listened to me and they started collecting the feces of
three months old and one year old kids.
Cause when we translate the most timelines,
that's what we were thinking of be early time period.
Then we looked at the feces in these and these kids at three months and one year
of age and what we've found is the feces of a three month old,
so that's a really itty bitty little baby for microbes.
If that kid had those microbes,
that kid,
we're not going to get asthma.
If that kid did not have those microbes,
that kid was at really high risk for asthma.
By the time they got to one year,
it didn't have any effect.
And so we did the really fun experiment where basically we took a germ free
animal so no microbes in it whatsoever and we took the feces from a three month
old kid that we knew actually went on to get asked but didn't have those four
bugs and we basically put that in this germ free animal or we took that same
thesis and spike in those four bugs and the put in that animal and we put those
four microbes into the human feces into this most you could actually then block
most asthma.
So that's as close as we are now to actually showing that these things are
actually playing a role.
But you could see where this can go.
You could actually think about it can't,
you could test her microbes and if they're,
if they don't have these four,
you could think about sort of a probiotic type intervention.
We're not there yet,
but that's where we're heading to.
So what about some of these other weed problems talked about obesity.
We know obesity is a major problem in our society.
What we're seeing is,
I actually changed this and put a Canadian map there cause I had an American map
but it looked too much like a political map of um,
you know,
so I think,
wow,
we will stick with Gannett and be safe here.
It actually does.
It's an uncanny when you look at obesity rates and political allegiances,
the,
I shouldn't say that.
Um,
anyway,
so,
so obesity is being a problem for a while where it's a real problem now is
pediatric obesity,
childhood obesity is just gone through the roof.
You're seeing these three,
four year olds are actually obese.
What do microbes have to do with this?
The answers everything.
So several years ago,
and I guy named Jeff Gordon,
did some really neat experiments.
We took a fat mouse and it a fecal transfer into thin bowls,
the thin most got fat.
He took a thin,
most did a fecal transfer of fat mouse that most got thin.
He took that people's feces put in thin,
my steak on fad,
the microbes CTB controlling this whole thing that actually makes sense because
the microbes break down a lot of what you eat.
And we know that in the obese,
um,
animals and people,
the microbes in there are really,
really good at generating extra energy for per unit of food coming in.
They're really good at it.
And,
um,
the microbes from the thin people are actually kind of woozy APP.
So that's a really neat stuff coming out in how microbes influence in this whole
thing.
Um,
there's this,
um,
uh,
Israeli friend of mine that,
that started this company.
It's called day two.
What he did is he made a bunch of Israelis were these glucose monitors around
and monitored all of microbes they had.
And all the food they're reading.
Now,
if you get a glucose spike that basically excess glucose spikes lead to obesity,
which then leads to type two diabetes so you don't want glucose spikes with your
food,
so he mapped all these microbes and all these food types based on that.
He can now analyze your feces for $300 and he will say you have these microbes
and based on that you should eat these foods and you have those microbes.
So based on that,
you can eat these.
And ironically,
some people can eat as much ice cream as they want,
they don't get glucose bites.
Others,
it just goes through and each person is different because they have different
microbes.
The really fun stuff is that when you then compare that head to head with the
standard diets,
Atkins,
weight watchers,
et Cetera,
it works great.
It just blows the others away.
So I think we're going to see the next few years,
this whole personalized diet kind of thing based on what your microbes are and
how they do
another major disease.
We're seeing a lot of his inflammatory bowel disease.
This is basically inflammation of the gut.
This is Crohn's and ulcerative colitis.
Basically your gut is on fire and it's a really tough disease.
But because it's the gut,
you can imagine there's microbes associated with this and they're really
starting to make some progress in here.
And they've actually been starting to do a lot of fecal transfer experiments.
And interestingly,
sometimes it works,
sometimes it doesn't.
Well it actually makes sense because we don't know what the perfect donor is
yet.
And so when a donor gives it,
you're asking these bugs to come in to put the fire out,
you know,
got on fire,
route out all the other bad bugs,
settle the inflammation down and take hold.
And that's a big ask.
So I think the whole thing with,
with IBD right now is we have to figure it out,
figure out who's stool has the,
the magic juice in terms of the bugs that could actually then do this.
One thing I will say about IBD is the only adverse effect so far correlated with
a fecal transfer is a thin woman who had IBD and she had no beast,
healthy sister.
So bees,
healthy sister donated her thesis to thin woman is her sister.
She got better,
Yay.
Chef's got obese bad.
So now the sister is suing the other sister for this.
So
that's the only fecals issue.
So an area I know would love that,
um,
that that we spent a lot of time on is diarrhea and microbes.
And we've already talked a little bit about c diff and the microbes and we've
done a lot of experiments in both Salmonella Nikolai showing the microbes were
really influenced the outcome of disease.
And so we're working at this in terms of preventing diarrhea in area.
Probably the most profound area I think that this is seeing a lot of interest in
is in the brain.
I told you that microbes and germ free animals that are germ free,
their brains don't develop normally and there's lots of studies coming out how
microbes,
you can take a depressed mouse stressed most or an anxious,
most put it into a normal mouse.
It will become stressed,
anxious or depressed simply by transferring the microbes.
Um,
there's lots of studies coming out indicating at this,
um,
autism.
There's,
which is obviously a,
you know,
a very contentious area right now.
There's,
there's hints hands-up microbes in it.
They definitely have different microbes,
but autistic kids might be eating differently.
There's an argument there.
There's a few one offs of fecal transfers were an autistic kid got to fecal
transfer seem to behavior became better.
So,
but it's,
and there's actually a study out last week or where they,
they did fecal transfers on 18 kids and saw a major improvement at eight weeks
in these 18 autistic kids.
So again,
there's hope that microbes might actually be influencing the brain.
So there really are influencing many,
many of these childhood diseases.
Okay,
well I think it's only one kid in the audience.
So,
or maybe they've even gone by now one bay,
but I want to talk about other aspects of life too,
because this is not just about babies.
It affects all of us.
Here's the top 10 reasons why you're going to die.
They get out of the CDC said,
yeah,
I know it's a great more of it slide,
but whatever.
When you look at this list,
how many of these are infectious?
One,
right?
Influenza pneumonia.
So that's,
that's flu.
You know,
he'd get pneumonia,
that that's infectious.
How many of these
are actually linked to microbes?
Turns out nine in these 10 diseases.
Now have a microbial link,
heart disease,
cancer,
lung diseases,
all of these things here,
you may think I'm crazy,
but actually they're starting to be some really nice data coming out.
Let's take a look at cardiovascular disease.
So that's basically,
if you blow a,
um,
uh,
an artery in the brain,
you have a stroke.
If it's in the body,
you have a heart attack.
So that's basically heart attacks and strokes combined.
And for a long time now we've known it's been associated with red meat and
things like that.
Well,
what is now being shown is that when you eat red,
neat,
the microbes take something called fossil.
Coleen,
it could put a red meat converted into a molecule.
So if they called Tma,
and that's the first step,
and then your body takes that molecule in liver and oxidize it to something
called Tma.
Oh,
this is what causes atherosclerosis.
So if you take a germ free mouse that has no microbes,
you see it as much red meat as one,
it doesn't get atherosclerosis.
Vegans and vegetarians have very low rates of this,
you know,
because they're not eating the red meat.
I think the most exciting study was when they actually made enzymes,
the block,
the microbial enzymes that do that first step and then test it lives in a most
model.
You could actually block it by drugging the bugs they'd been trying to drug the
second half,
which is a Christian,
your liver.
But all the drugs have been talks and how many are able to do it.
So here's a neat way for two major diseases where there's obviously my critical
component,
probably the funnest experiment I saw these guys do,
is they convinced a Vegan who had never eaten a steak in their life to eat a
steak.
I don't know how they did that.
But anyway,
so Vegan eats a steak.
They measure what happens.
What do you think would happen?
It turns out that because this person never had steaks,
they don't have the microbes to actually do that.
So nothing happened.
The Vega didn't make the products,
especially with atherosclerosis because they didn't have the bugs in the first
place to do it.
So,
you know,
we've talked a little bit of this already,
but stress and anxiety and depression,
this whole mind thing is that we,
I should say the only one on the list,
I couldn't attribute to microbes for accidents.
So he can't say the microbes made me do it.
Honest.
Um,
there's a big study just came out of the UK correlating antibiotic use with,
with basically anxiety and depression.
And bottom line is more courses of antibiotics.
The more anxious than depressed you'll be.
Antifungals and antivirals had no effect.
So that's,
you know,
again,
sort of pointing to is we talked about autism,
Adhd jetlag.
I just came back from Europe.
It's sucks.
We all know jet lag.
It hurts,
right?
The same Israeli guy that did the um,
obese died,
this guy's crazy.
He basically convinces Grad students to go to all these meetings around the
world,
collect their feces,
be jet lagged and come back.
Right.
And the way he did it,
this is great.
He flew in business class.
So,
um,
what grads dude is going to say no to a quick flight too,
you know,
Israel to London and back,
right?
And then you just collect the poop and what happens?
It turns out microbes actually have a big influence on circadian rhythm,
which is what jet lag is.
And they're actually a starting to show that by affecting these microbial
composition,
you can actually affect circadian rhythm.
So I'm dying for the day.
When you actually take a probiotic before to Europe,
you know,
and you,
you actually feel normal.
So again,
you know,
this whole gut brain access,
these microbes are doing it.
They're talking to the brain and the brain's talking to the microbes
while we're on the brain.
And you know,
major issues are,
um,
degenerative brain diseases.
So this is Alzheimer's and Parkinson's.
These are very scary diseases.
But as our population ages,
they're becoming more and more prevalent.
Turns out there are actually things you can do that microbial link that actually
can influence your,
your rate of outcome of these things.
There's this diet called the mind diet,
which is basically a modified Mediterranean diet.
It's not actually that hard.
It's glass of red wine,
you know,
and eating the fruits,
vegetables,
legumes and nuts,
your,
your mother tells you to eat kind of thing.
The stylish to had spectacular results.
If you ate this kind of a diet,
you could decrease your risk for Alzheimer's by 50%.
I mean that is really profound.
If you didn't stick to it even perfectly,
but you did stick to it,
you can basically decrease it by about 25 to 30%.
So that's his diet plays a big role in,
in,
in dementia and Alzheimer's.
And I said these are western diseases and it turns out the,
um,
the loss rates of,
of,
um,
dementia and Alzheimer's are actually a rural India,
which obviously has a higher microbial right there.
Here's a fun little study I found.
If you remember anything from this talk,
just brush your teeth.
If you brush your teeth three times a day,
you could see the numbers here that you can drop it by 22 to 65% of getting
dementia.
They didn't say anything with dental floss,
so I can't help you there.
Um,
and then they also had this really nice twin study where one twin had good oral
health and the other had poor oral health and the one with the poor oral health
had much,
much higher rates of,
of,
of dementia.
So what does it happen?
Why,
why is good oral health?
Well,
turns out the biggest problem with aging is what we call inflammation.
This low grade inflammation in our body.
And so if you have poor oral health,
all these microbes are seeping through your gums and your body is then getting
inflamed.
And this basically contributes to many of the effects of aging,
especially dementia and Alzheimer's.
So more of the stories brush your teeth can't hurt.
Right.
And,
um,
what studies say it actually might do something.
Okay,
let's finish up with a bit more practical stuff that those who do have kids and
you know,
talk about what we might do.
Okay.
If micros important,
how do we fix it?
What can we do about it?
You know,
to do this.
So I think that the trick is to think of a balance.
So obviously we've come a long ways of preventing kids a dieting infections.
That's great.
The hygiene actually works and that's been important and it's done really well,
but we realized,
I think we've tipped the scales too far and we now have to basically bring it
back to these kids to have to be exposed to the microbes that they're used to
getting exposed to.
We've evolved with these things and allow this healthy exposure.
Okay,
when does it start?
It starts when the mother's pregnant and there's all sorts of neat things coming
out showing that these microbes in the mother are actually effecting how the
fetus develops is inside the mother.
For example,
if you're a thin mother in third trimester,
so and you say,
oh,
I'm pregnant,
I can gain 500 pounds for once in my life.
They don't have to die,
you know,
and all this,
and you gain more weight than you should.
Third Trimester mothers,
they're microbes are already going towards obese because it gives me more energy
to drive the fetus.
Remember intelligent than me,
more energy.
If you really overeat,
you really drive your kids to your,
your microbes.
To obesity when the kid is born,
that kid inherits mother's microbes.
That kid stands a much higher chance of being obese even though the mother was
thin to begin with just by mother's microbes.
We've talked a lot about the,
the first birthday present of the big gulp on the way out.
This is really important because the microbes the kid acquires these are the
ones and actually breakdown breast milk.
Um,
these are the ones that feed the kid and um,
and the vaginal microbes through,
they're beneficial.
They're like probiotic bugs.
So it's really important to get acquired to this.
And we're working with a company now that is becoming rather popular in some
circles too.
If you have to have a c section,
you do a vaginal swab,
which is just like,
it sounds,
just swallow the vagina,
kid is born and then your smear the microbes all over the mice and things like
this to try to knock,
leave that kid with.
Um,
with this,
the studies are not long enough yet to know whether it works or not,
but um,
it's underway in natural pass routinely doing this.
Yeah.
Breastfeeding,
I've already told you,
we all,
we know breastfeeding is better.
We've always thought because it had mother's antibodies in there.
For example,
while we now know that in breast milk,
most of breastmilk,
our bodies can't break down.
We don't have the enzyme to do it.
We rely on those microbes of the kid acquired upon birth to actually break down
the breast mound.
And more recently there's a bunch of studies now showing that,
um,
that there's actually microbes in breast milk.
They're actually involved in colonizing in the kit and doing it.
So interestingly,
it's got all the formula companies scrambling.
Now,
you know,
how can we,
improve formula to,
to put these kinds of things in here.
Okay.
Kids starting to grow up where they do,
um,
one of the left Pinky soother.
What do you want to call?
Parents use this all the time.
Pacifier,
right?
You're putting the kids most with the kids do spit it out.
Right?
Put it back in.
Real Fun game you,
I'll spit it out.
You know,
it goes in the floor.
Here's a shopping center.
What do you do?
Well that fell at a study that they basically,
these parents have two choices.
You can go into the washroom and wash it off and put it back in the kid.
We just putting your own mouth and shovel back in the kid.
If you put in your own mouth and shovel and the kid's face,
those kids have much less asthma,
obesity and allergies.
Then if you run to the washroom and wash it up so it saves a trip guys,
you know you can,
and especially for guys because we're lazy,
you know,
just shut up.
Good.
You know kind of thing.
Yeah,
I love that picture there.
He's a better picture here.
Here we go.
It's understand advanced kills the most germs.
It kills more than 99.9% of germs leaves the hands feeling soft.
Chuckit this is poison.
You guys should not be using this.
All the studies show it doesn't work and the FDA has actually try chlorella and
is the active ingredient is actually is just bandit because there's no studies
to show this actually works.
So,
you know,
playground,
every diaper bag has got one of these hanging off of it,
right?
I mean,
this,
you don't need to do this.
Soap of water is all you need.
And also when you use this on your hands,
you're actually killing off all the good microbes and increasing the chance of
bad one coming in and being able to call them ice.
So you've gotten rid of the competitors that were good in the first place.
So throw all the hand sanitizer,
all gonna make your life easy.
You don't even have to do that.
Just maybe wash the kids' hands before dinner.
But that's it.
Kids,
why do kids do they get dirty,
right?
I mean,
you know,
Hoover in kids,
they just love to eat dirt and play in the dirt and everything.
So if dirty exposure was so bad,
don't you think as a species we would evolve not to get dirty all the time.
And what does a kid do?
Puts everything in the possible in the mouth,
right?
You know,
they just Hoover everything.
Why?
My argument is they're trying to get some of the microbes from the world and
we're trying,
no,
don't put that in your mouth,
please.
No,
don't you in that stick kind of thing.
So you know,
maybe,
maybe there's a recent to it.
Okay,
here's one I really like.
Get a dog.
What a dog's do.
They do two things.
They roll around in the dirt,
especially thinking finds a feces and everything else and they get really dirty,
right?
Then they come bounding into the house and they roll over the kid and like the
kid and everything.
Right.
It turns out that if you get a dog and you have a young kid in the house,
you would decrease that kid's chance of getting asthma by 20% and you also
decrease the chances of obesity.
That kid,
just by the simple fact of having this dog,
cat lovers,
what do you think?
Sorry guys.
Cast.
Just sit in the car and they go like this.
You know,
and they're not liking the kid.
There's no dad at either way.
Cats don't improve or just proof.
That's because they don't think they interface with the kids as much.
So you know that anyway.
I don't mean to install a cat lovers not getting in trouble here.
I know.
So,
okay.
How do you change your microbes?
The easiest way is what you eat.
You know the expression is you are what you eat.
I argue you microbes are what you eat.
So we eat a lot of white flour and white sugar now,
right?
These are processed foods.
They're actually absorbed by the body really quickly in the upper end test.
I'm in small and test time because you don't have to break these things down.
She gave this great McNeil and Mcdonald's or whatever and it's going there.
Most of it is absorbed long before it ever gets to where the microbes are,
which is way down in the gut.
So ironically,
you know your mother was right eat your vegetables and nuts and legumes and high
fiber,
not so much for the nutrients,
but if you're actually feeding the microbes and all the studies show that this
more of a healthy diet and you know,
decreased red meat and things is actually feeding the microbes to actually allow
them to do their thing.
So
this is an experiment we did lab and each of those colors,
the different microbes in untreated and then different mice treated of two
different antibiotics.
Antibiotics drastically impact on the microbes.
The average kid in the U s gets 10 to 12 courses of antibiotics by the time they
get to school.
The reason that's a problem is early in life,
these microbes are bouncing around and if you have an antibiotic is shift that
kids,
microbes,
they come back a bit but not the same.
Then he hit him again.
It goes for like this and by 10 12 courses,
these microbes are over here,
antibiotics,
we all know about the causing resistance to use them,
but we now know is they're actually not harmless.
And so you have to balance them.
You know,
if the kid is dying,
bacterial infection,
of course you use antibiotics.
But if the kid has a viral infection,
antibiotics don't work against viruses.
Wait 24
hours and see what's happening.
The biggest crime in antibiotics and u s and Canada,
80% of her antibiotic use is used in agriculture because that gives you a 15%
increase in growth weight.
They banned it in Europe.
And,
but the problem is that gives a 50% increase in growth in any animal pigs,
sheep,
fish,
what are the cow is you name it.
And the studies show humans.
So you'll maybe the success of antibiotic use in our world is actually
influenced the major obesity epidemic we're seeing.
So if you follow me so far and you're starting to buy in,
yeah,
maybe these microbes important.
Here's an interesting concept.
Every generation,
our society gets cleaner.
Every generation we have less and less diverse microbes to choose from.
You cannot go back to the how the microbes,
your great,
great grandfather or grandmother had,
he can't get them unless they're alive and hey,
give me sound kind of thing.
But,
um,
you know,
and you know,
every generation.
So maybe we need to rethink these guys.
These are actually endangered species.
We've evolved with these microbes.
Yeah,
we're bonding.
I'm like crazy know we can't go back.
We don't have the answer.
But you know,
maybe we've got to rethink this about,
cause we evolved with these things.
They're designed for us and we know we have these things.
And so,
um,
you know,
interesting thoughts.
Finally I have to put a plug in for vaccines.
There's been an awful lot of misinformation and mal information on this and to
all the data vaccines worked.
You know,
the whole autism was fraudulent and it's been completely just proven and
everything.
And if you do have kids do the vaccines,
it's really,
um,
I mean,
you know,
there's been a recent political appointments.
I would reevaluate vaccines in the states by vaccine denier that is going to
cost a lot of kids' lives.
The first Bush did the experiment when they banned the whooping cough vaccine.
Lots of kids died because it just came roaring back.
And so I think we've got to remember that vaccines are really wonderful tool for
many of these diseases.
So this is a book that I've written with a coauthor,
a postdoc mind clear Arietta and this is a book that's for sale back there that
really takes us through all this.
It's designed for,
the science is behind it,
but it's designed that anyone can read.
It's not technical,
it's made for the person.
And the Nice thing I think about this book as we seem to have got the balance
right,
the pediatricians agree with it and even the naturopathic degree with it.
So the whole balance thing,
and it's full of helpful hints on how to do the kid.
There's chapters and asthma,
obesity and diabetes and many other diseases affect all of us in our life.
Um,
and I'll refer you to the website and let them eat dirt.com.
We put up a bunch of information there if you're interested in this.
And if you're going to ask him about probiotics,
there's a really nice blank just clicking the probiotics and we'll take you to
the clinical studies that show which probiotics work for what disease.
There's a few,
they work,
but most of them they don't.
So I will stand around afterwards and maybe we'll sell a few books and sign
these things.
And so finally,
I guess I want to leave you with a message.
This is Seattle.
It's like Vancouver rains a lot.
I thought there was an appropriate picture here.
We need to let kids be kids experience the world because they have to do that to
pick up their microbes then be healthy.
Thanks a lot.
[inaudible]
so thank you Dr. Finley.
Uh,
we have a few minutes for questions.
Thanks.
This is really interesting.
Um,
so are there any circumstances where you would recommend,
uh,
like an alcohol based sanitizer?
Like if I'm camping or something,
I have no running water.
You know,
maybe I'm,
I'm digging cat holes and stuff.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah,
that,
that's the whole hygiene question that if you are,
you know,
a daycare and everyone's squirting,
everybody got diarrhea and things definitely watched the hand.
So,
so this works for,
for the,
the hygiene kind of concept of it.
But just for daily maintenance,
the answer is no,
it doesn't do a tall,
so use it,
you know,
if you're in a hospital setting for example,
there was a reason that they use hand sanitizer there,
but we honestly don't need it here.
Really.
Yeah.
Great.
Thank you.
Great question.
Do you foresee the development of a,
uh,
ideal series of,
of um,
biome cocktails or,
or,
uh,
um,
that are,
that are designed so that a,
you give this,
uh,
within 24 hours of birth,
you give that one was x number of weeks.
You have that one with him x number of months so that um,
uh,
kids will have a,
a idealized,
a biome in the gut.
Yeah,
absolutely.
I mean,
I'm going to call it probiotics 2.0 kind of thing.
I cofounded a company in Boston is doing exactly that.
They're doing the vaginal recolonization.
They're thinking about screening.
If you've got risk for asthma or not,
you could then repopulate these things.
The thing about probiotics is that,
that they're,
they're often from the vagina and you're putting them in the gut.
They don't stick.
There's a reason they say you have to take 10 billing and things a date because
they just flushed through you.
So I think in the future it'll be a pill that contains,
you know,
20 different microbes from the gut for the God.
And we know these microbes have this particular benefit.
So we repopulate the whole ecological system with these microbes.
So yeah,
I think,
I think probiotics the future are very exciting and we're still early days on
identifying which microbes are going to give us this particular benefit.
Um,
this field is only really about seven to 10 years old.
So it's,
it's really,
um,
gearing up.
But I think we're going to see major changes in this area and it's a lot easier
to give a probiotic then.
Well,
we can't do gene therapy now,
for example.
So I think we're going to see a lot of that.
Yeah.
So my question is,
do you have any advice for adults with some of the conditions you mentioned?
Yeah,
I mean a lot of the similar concepts apply.
So diet is a major thing.
Um,
and um,
I think things like asthma,
that's because it's early life immune system either.
I haven't seen any data that later in life he effect you could affect asthma.
Um,
but things like IBD for example,
obesity,
diabetes,
there's some neat stuff coming out.
Even things like cancer,
chemotherapy,
there's some beautiful studies coming out now that they can tell whether you
respond to chemo or not depending on what microbes you have and they actually
predict with these things.
So see,
I'm toyed with writing a book,
you know,
the other end of life as age and I've been studying this a lot,
but there are certainly,
um,
you know,
probiotics not going to hurt.
You can take those kinds of things.
I think,
you know,
Diet and exercise is a major component cause both of those influences in
microbes and depends on certain conditions,
you know,
and pay attention the literature because it's coming fast.
There's a lot of stuff coming out,
but you got to filter it and look at,
there's a lot of quackery out there too and do that but,
but it does certainly coming.
Yeah.
Cool.
Thanks.
Yup.
Is there any interesting data around a,
like when kids are in daycare,
buses home more versus in growing up in a village with a city?
Yeah,
there's certainly is.
Um,
it's interesting that this whole hygiene hypothesis,
the idea where to clean early,
that was discovered by realizing that the younger siblings have less diseases
and stuff when the older ones,
because the older kids,
I brought all this stuff home too.
So there's no data to say that getting infections and kids is good for kids.
Like you don't,
you don't have to get an infection,
but there's no doubt that,
you know,
when a kid hits daycare for then use had done that.
You know,
immediately you're going to have a year of colds and you and your kids are going
to suffer need,
you know,
um,
but yes,
you can see shifts in their microbes.
Um,
the question I'm wondering is,
okay,
so you're a mother and you have a kid by c section and you have mastitis,
she can't breastfeed and you live on the 22nd floor of a condo in an urban
setting and you have no pets and your daycare's down the door,
I'm down the hall,
you know,
I wonder how are these kids going to get,
sort of normal things.
So Dennis speaking daycare is a good way of mixing up the microbes except when
the infections come.
And that's,
you know,
that's when,
they just ripped through the daycare.
So yeah,
you and you can certainly tell microbes are real read on the environment.
Like we can tell in the feces whether the family has a dog or not.
Cause you have dog microbes in there.
That's easy to see.
And we can tell what kind of dog it is based on the microbial composition and
that they need to.
But,
um,
so,
so the environment really does influence.
And so,
um,
there,
there's,
there's a lot of studies coming out to daycare,
sort of enhances this whole community exposure to microbes cause you do get
different microbes and if you're just solely staying at home and never seen
other kid.
Yeah.
Neat question.
So you didn't show the map but you kind of,
I'm sorry you didn't show the map and you alluded to the fact that there is a
correlation between say obesity rates and demographics and possibly political
inclinations.
I don't like going there.
Maybe,
maybe not,
but I'm kind of curious why that actually is.
Is it because you know,
people in certain parts of the country wash their hands more use hand sanitizer
or is it nutrition or do we not know
since your diet and exercise is what the epidemiologists attributed to and um,
major high fat diet and lack of exercise in the southern areas of the states for
example.
And um,
yeah,
that's,
that's what they claim.
I have not seen a hand sander to like,
you know,
just,
southern US use more or less hand sanitizer in the north.
I don't know about that.
I don't think it's that,
I think it's just the whole environment these people are living in.
Yeah.
Thanks very much for your talk.
Um,
I'm uh,
a weight loss surgery,
a patient and I'm very interested to know your opinion on that particular Spec
perspective.
I've had to switch myself to probiotics,
right.
Um,
but you know,
rather,
really any discussion before going into the surgery that um,
you're going to be changing your microbial levels and stuff.
And so I'm very interested enough,
there's like studies out there on that or anything like that.
They're just coming on.
I've seen several now raise then,
you know,
from very,
I'd surgery really does affect the microbes cause you're really taking a piece
of the intestine in that sense.
Um,
what that means in terms of health complications down the line.
I have not seen the,
I think it's still early days in that sense,
but there's no doubt you do shift the microbes anytime you do something to the
and test time and,
and you're right.
A lot of the probiotics,
as I say,
they can't hurt.
They seem to help digestion and things.
And there's your,
you know,
punk Titus for example.
There's some nice data that probiotic seem to actually decrease that,
for example.
So,
yeah.
Yeah.
Okay.
Thanks.
I'm wondering about probiotics,
including a small number of identified microbes versus broad spectrum,
natural exposure.
How many different microbes do we have?
How many different microbes does someone who's living in natural conditions and
the Amazon have?
And what are the chances that we can identify the microbes that matter so that,
oh,
where the research is right now,
there's about a thousand generally split a thousand species of microbes in your
gut.
And each person I said is different.
There's about three,
300 or so in your mouth that are different.
The skin,
there's probably about a hundred or so different ones.
Um,
with respect to the Amazon and things,
there's been some various who studies dunning on the microbes of these people
have had very little exposure to the outside world.
And um,
their microbes are very different,
but they're dying is very different to,
and actually one anthropologist was so convinced he did it.
He gave himself a fecal transfer with this primitive,
if you want to call it that theses.
And he just got severe diarrhea and he got into real trouble in that sense.
So that experiment didn't work.
Um,
but you're right.
So the idea is Kenyan biobank really,
you know,
can we save the good ones?
Okay,
these ones are good.
We need these things and bio and there's groups that are certainly working at
that.
And that's really where the research is right now to,
you know,
biobank has this diversity of these microbes,
and try and figure which ones are important.
Yeah,
thanks for the talk.
It was very enjoyable.
Thanks.
So my first question is how literally should we take the title of your book in
the following sense?
So my spouse was a big proponent of home vegetable gardens from my daughter when
she was very young and she seems to be doing very well now and good.
Um,
so like is there a benefit to actually eating fruits,
vegetables that are like semi unwashed and so forth.
Um,
and my second question was related to one of the maps you showed about asthma.
I look like globally.
It was a western world problem except for Brazil.
Oh,
well we'll do that.
Brazil is a great story.
Yeah.
Okay.
So title,
I mean,
let kids see the microbes that are found within the third sometimes to help
replenish.
And we'll never make a title right.
So it's a bit tongue in cheek,
you know,
Hillary,
a best seller to that.
So it's a bit tongue and cheek.
Um,
I think we can safely say that,
you know,
if,
if a kid picks up a handful of dirt today,
it's much safer than a handful of dirt.
A hundred years ago he had cholera,
smallpox,
you know,
all these,
um,
other nasty things.
So it's safer in that sense.
And,
um,
but it,
you know,
I,
a lot of that is starting to show that,
you know,
I had as a kid,
you pull carrots,
old scrape the dirt off,
most of it,
they just chew on it,
right.
And you can taste the dirt and things.
You're getting good microbial exposure there.
That's probably good for them.
You know,
say if a kid's,
you know,
let the good play in the sandbox,
unless there's cat feces there and then don't cause that has parasites in it for
example,
or like the Floria House,
that's okay,
but not the subway station.
That's probably not okay kind of thing.
So,
so it's a balance.
Um,
I've not seen any studies have actually ramming dirt down a kid's mouth and
saying,
you know,
this isn't good for you or not.
I mean,
more the unwashed carrot variety.
Right?
Yeah.
I think that's really good.
And that,
that's another way of microbial exposure.
The Brazil story.
So you picked it up.
There's um,
um,
Brazil was bright red for asthma to,
and the question is why cause it,
you don't associate with being a fully developed country gap.
Turns out in Brazil,
c-sections are a range.
So about 80% of people in Brazil gets c-sections and about 95% of the women in
Rio de Janeiro and get c-sections.
Part of that is it's trendy.
It's like cool to have your little bikini scar kind of thing.
But also the other part is the obstetricians are unionized and they're union
says you don't do night call.
So if you want to deliver a kid,
you've got to do it during daylight hours.
So I don't have to get up at nine deliver this thing.
So it's really going to various who follow what happens to all of these kids
that are born by c section.
You know,
cause we're going to see it,
see the cohort,
some of them.
And so there's a big movement now to try and convince these obstetrician then
maybe kids,
maybe you do have to get up in the night and do a normal vaginal delivery
sometimes for the health of these kids.
I don't know if that's why Brazil is so high.
Um,
but that,
I mean we know that CSX has really increased asthma rates.
I'm sure that contributes to it.
Yeah.
Thanks.
Okay,
thanks a lot.
Hi.
You talked a lot about,
um,
health and eating and,
that you can eat healthy,
you to,
uh,
improve,
I dunno the outcomes and so forth,
but are there specific foods that are linked to healthy microbes that you should
eat more of other than just hello?
Yes,
and the answer,
it's all the ones that grow on the picture.
It is the plants.
It's the legumes,
the nuts,
the,
um,
just the highly complex,
unprocessed foods,
as I was saying,
you know,
white sugar,
white,
white flour,
processed meats.
These are at the other end of the spectrum in terms of driving obesity type
microbes.
Um,
and like I say,
the stuff that's being done with day to go personalized diets showing which
foods are good and bad for it,
for each person.
Um,
Delis speaking,
the moral of the story is,
you know,
it's,
it's an old story,
but now we know it's the microbes,
not just because he used to be,
you'd get your lettuce because it gives you fight amens and things.
Now,
no.
Now we also show that actually twists your microbes in a much more beneficial
way.
So I think the whole western diet is,
is the worst site we can have for microbes when you actually look at it.
And the better diets are the,
you know,
the more plant and legume based type things.
People did a lot.
Um,
um,
you know,
beans and things like this.
There's a book called the blue zones,
which is areas in the world where people live forever.
Like since centurions a hundred years,
2% turns 105 years.
And what these people have in common is they have social contacts.
Their 80 year old daughter looks after their hundred year old parent.
They have families or they,
um,
they also have exercise.
They've walked down to the town center to play cards with their buddies or
whatever all the time and they don't eat very much red meat and need a lot of
legumes and things.
And they know they have a pig roast once a year for new year's.
That's okay,
but you don't have to eat as much meat type thing.
And that is a trend of the seven areas around the world.
That's what they all have in common.
So I think Diane's going to see a major resurgence as we realize,
you know,
some of the other reasons why you actually need to think about what you eat,
but for sure,
um,
what you think of a healthy eating that's actually gives you a healthy microbes.
The data shows that.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Yeah,
a very interesting talk.
Thank you very much for coming today.
Uh,
I have a 13 month old,
so that's why I love it.
Mainly focused on this right now.
Um,
the one quick comment I heard,
uh,
no mention of one of the things that was highlighted when we were sort of
preparing for her arrival,
which was a new focus,
relatively new focus on early skin to skin contact with the mother.
Um,
you mentioned that sort of vaginal swabs,
but I didn't,
I was a little surprised not to hear that mentioned.
Well,
most of the benefits,
there's some on the skin,
but not as many as one of the giant of,
for example.
So the studies are unclear right now.
So far,
you know,
should you immediate latch on the breast for microbial exposure kind of thing.
Um,
a lot of people are starting to think that,
but the dad is not strong yet.
Okay.
Yeah.
Um,
what I really wanted to ask is,
uh,
I had a parent recently tell me,
that the eating the same thing with the child was a negative for the child in
terms of tooth decay because our floor was so different.
And like,
uh,
if I took a bite of something that she was taking,
then a bite of,
uh,
like really surprised me and I was hoping you would
get first shower shower.
Yeah.
So no evidence you've heard of ever just support that.
And one of the other things I've wondered is,
uh,
is there a point at which,
it becomes less important to have this sort of,
you know,
to let them eat dirt?
Yeah.
At least five years of age is kind of,
then it obviously influences all of us at all ages,
but really the,
I call the book ends of life zero five and the 65 plus.
That's when the microbes seem to have an even more,
um,
then middle life,
it's things like diabetes and obesity,
and then that's just standard.
Um,
uh,
well physical being type things that they seem to play a role,
but the early life because you're setting up and the later life,
I think immune system goes wonky in the bunk,
go wonky.
So
awesome.
So I've still got some time with her then.
Yeah,
absolutely.
there's still hope.
Thanks.
Yeah.
All right.
So thank you very much again.
Thank you very much.
[inaudible].